imagino que puedes estar de preguntando
por qué querrían realizar un intercambio
o estar dispuestos a tomar el riesgo de
la contraparte personas capacitadas para
negociar este tipo de contratos futuros
estandarizados y la primera razón es que
el intercambio se hace para realizar
mucho dinero lo que ellos pueden hacer
es decirle a la gente a quienes quieren
comprar manzanas en el futuro decirle al
cliente hey puedes entrar en un contrato
futuro con un precio de liquidación de
22 centavos por libra así que lo que
ellos harán es ir y comprarte a 22
centavos la libra y después le puede
decir a la gente que cuando les toque la
entrega de las manzanas los precios de
liquidación están a 20 centavos por
libra por lo que esencialmente cuando la
liquidación ocurra estarás listo para
ganar 2 centavos estarás haciendo 2
centavos así que lo voy a explicar una
vez más pues si ellos deben pagarles a
20 centavos a estas personas la libra de
manzana y al principio habían dicho que
dan 20 centavos por libra tal vez aquí
deberíamos de recalcarlo porque
es el precio actual de las manzanas más
no el precio de entrega y si estos
chicos llegaran a irse por arriba del
precio de las manzanas en lugar de los
20 centavos para los agricultores ellos
estarían haciendo 2 centavos de ganancia
y bueno ahora si me voy al peso como del
contrato si este es por mil toneladas el
contrato costaría 20 dólares se pagarán
20 dólares por el contrato y bien esto
es en cuanto al precio del contrato y en
cuanto a las ganancias como que podría
haber pero ahora si analizamos un
poquito más todo esto podrá llegar un
momento en el que se pudiera necesitar
negociar o tener un nuevo comercio con
todos los diferentes agricultores y
todos los diferentes clientes e incluso
con algunos especuladores que quisieran
hacer esto la idea es cómo rediseñar el
contrato aún así estando estandarizado
para obtener algo mejor ahora por otro
lado si él quisiera protegerse a sí
mismo contra las pérdidas y suponiendo
que él puede estar en cualquiera de
ambas partes dejando un poco de lado de
dinero en el caso en que el precio del
contrato futuro se mueva en contra de
ellos
ese dinero funcionaría para el famoso
llamado margen
de ambas partes el margen quiero
explicar mejor en el siguiente vídeo
presencialmente es el monto de dinero
que este chico o esta persona aportan
como un resguardo que es una cantidad de
dinero que se deja como de reserva y a
lo que me refiero con esto es que
funciona como una especie de seguro así
que nosotros podemos casi asegurar que
la fecha de liquidación de entrega ambas
partes estarán listas para conocer sus
obligaciones pero profundizar mejor en
el margen en el siguiente vídeo